at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking when I ask you a personal
question okay I must - any organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
[Music]
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
99designs whether you need a logo custom
website app book cover or anything else
99designs was created to make great
design accessible to everyone that's you
and to make the process as easy as
possible I've used 99 designs for years
now I've used them for book covers some
mock-ups for the 4-hour body which went
on to become a number one New York Times
bestseller illustrations of all
different types for the multi-volume The
Tao of Seneca which you can check out
and other graphic design projects for a
long time now and I've been very
impressed by the quality of their
designers in illustrators and you don't
have to take my word for it you should
check out some of my projects at
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim I
really encourage you to take a look
because you will be impressed 99designs
comm forward slash Tim 99designs has
freelance experts in more than 90 design
categories in their platform lets you
work directly with one designer that you
choose if you like their stuff which is
what I did for the town of Seneca or you
can get concepts from multiple designers
and then pick your favorite so whether
you're starting a business or just
looking for extra design help resources
etc 99designs has a solution right now
you guys my listeners can receive a free
$99 upgrade on your first design to
check out your first free upgrade please
visit 99designs calm a forward slash Tim
and click the link on the landing page
you can also find their samples of
projects from you guys listeners who
have used 99 designs for logos apps even
product packaging so check it out 99
designs com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom which more than 2 million
Americans have used to help start their
businesses past guests even such as well
WordPress lead developer CEO of
automatic Matt Mullenweg now valued at
more than a billion dollars have used
LegalZoom to help with their business
needs specifically in his case to form
his company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business their services
include everything from helping you to
manage changing tax laws reviewing
contracts creating NDA's non-disclosure
agreements important stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
business the best part is that you won't
get charged by the hour
because LegalZoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get a la carte style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lower case I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers of
various types in each and every episode
however not in this episode this will be
an exception so if you want long form
interviews teasing out the habits
routines and so on of these various
experts in different fields I would
suggest you go to Tim blog forward slash
podcast there are more than 300 of them
if you're going for entertaining I would
suggest maybe starting with Jamie Foxx
you can find that at teamed up blog
forward slash Jamie and if you want
something really deep and profound you
start with say BJ Miller just search BJ
Miller and my name Tim Ferriss and there
are certainly many many many many others
in between relationships if you want to
dig into that look for Esther Perel
among others but back to this episode
this episode is going to by popular
request contain case studies
specifically we will be looking at
million-dollar one-person businesses and
in a way you could think of this as case
studies from the 4-hour workweek it's
exceptionally hard to believe for me at
least I had a lot more hair back when
the 4-hour workweek was written but it
was published let alone written it was
published more than 10 years ago it's
about the 11th anniversary almost
exactly as I record this and it amazes
me that the book continues to strike a
chord no one expected the book to do
anything for those who don't know it was
turned down by 27 publishers very
violently overtly in some cases and the
initial print run was around 10,000
copies and that does not give you even
national distribution it was a hard book
to find to begin with and despite all
that here we are
and last year 2007 I was sent this year
in books 2017 by Amazon charts by a
friend and the 4-hour workweek was as I
read the infographic the most
highlighted book across all of Amazon in
2017 which is crazy so I thought that it
might be worthwhile as much as certain
passages in
book make me cringe because I was a 29
year old with lots of chest puffing I've
never wanted to edit it and to fuss with
it because I'm afraid of stepping on the
butterfly and killing whatever magic
ended up being gifted to me and being
channeled into that book somehow so I
don't want to fuss with it I may update
certain resources but in the meantime I
thought I could do that visa V case
studies and while many people have
misunderstood the title and not read the
book because it is about doing more with
your life and with your time every hour
that you are given your hourly output
versus doing a little and laying on a
beach rubbing cocoa butter on your belly
for the rest of your life the blueprint
itself has been put into action by now
hundreds of thousands of people and much
like the four-minute mile was thought to
be impossible until it was broken by
Bannister and immediately thereafter
more and more people began to break it
because among other reasons it was
believed to be possible it was proven to
be possible because someone had done it
and I love reading case studies that
come to me or that I hear about so I
thought I would share a few and maybe
for those of you listening who are
putting off perhaps entrepreneurship or
experimenting with lifestyle design
until some day which is a dangerous way
to phrase things in your own head
because it's very often something you'll
take to the grave with you the the
traffic lights of life are very rarely
all green at the same time so there's
really never a convenient time to do the
most important things in life whether
that's proposing getting a divorce
having a kid quitting your job starting
a company there's never really a
convenient time to do any of these
things so perhaps some of the stories or
one of the stories that we're going to
talk about will serve as the four-minute
mile for you where you will see that it
is in fact possible to take maybe even
one tiny small step towards testing a
different reality for yourself and doing
so at very very low risk so let's move
forward this entire episode is based on
a guest blog post
Alaine po felt and I may be massacring
her name and I'm going to certainly
butcher other names throughout this
Elaine POF pldt which was adapted and
extended as an excerpt from her latest
book which is called the million dollar
one-person business so I'll say that
again the million dollar one-person
business by Elaine Poe felt and we
connected and have connected several
times over the years about various
things for magazines and she had
mentioned to me in an email that several
people had cited the 4-hour workweek as
inspiration or as a collection of tools
they used when starting their business
and that's how we began this
conversation about featuring a handful
of folks where that played a part and
there are six different people we're
gonna discuss and some of them have
built very very large businesses some of
them have decided after building what
would be called a muse and automated
cash flow business in the 4-hour
workweek to then turn it into something
more traditional or conventional and
that is totally allowed because most of
the rules aren't rules at all
you make the rules for yourself in most
cases outside of a handful of places
like law and even then you can hire good
lawyers or lobbyists and sometimes
change the law but I digress let's get
back to the case studies and this is
going to be an unusual experiment for me
because I will be reading something that
Elaine wrote in her voice so you will
note that it may sound like excessive
chest thumping for the 4-hour workweek
and so on but this was written by Elaine
with a few minor minor minor
modifications on my part and this is
also a test for me if you want to learn
more about case studies if you want more
case studies related to the 4-hour
workweek or anything else what have se
listeners and readers of mine actually
done with this information what are
their trials and tribulations for say
someone who's lost a hundred pounds 200
pounds whatever it might be I've met
both by the way or someone who's built a
massive company and decided hey I want
to turn this into an Inc 500 a rapidly
growing company that perhaps is at some
point can be acquired or IPO or those
people who have decided to keep it
really small one person two people maybe
as a couple
and they're running a multi-billion
dollar business let me know if you want
more case studies because I am thinking
of doing something on going with this
but I want to make sure that there is
demand for it so let me know on Twitter
at T Farris TF er Riss or let me know on
the blog post for this which is very
easy to find and you can just search Tim
Ferriss Alain PO felt and it will be one
of the first results that pop up I am
sure you can also find that at end up
blog forward slash podcast so either way
if you're interested or uninterested in
more case studies on the podcast and
elsewhere please let me know and I will
come back to this but I'll mention it
one more time if you want say 20 or 30
more of these case studies I've already
put them together and you can find some
of them on Tim dot blog if you look at
the topics on the right hand side you
will find Muse examples and there are
nine posts I think each one contains at
least three or four examples so let's
get into it the following is going to be
Alain Lazlo Nadler that's la s ZL o
thirty-six lives a life many dream of he
is on track to bring in more than two
million dollars a year in a profitable
business that is a one-man show Nadler
runs a five-year-old online store tools
for wisdom that's tools the number for
wisdom com from his home in New Jersey
the store sells inspirational weekly and
monthly planners Nadler outsources the
printing so most of his daily work
consists of customer service business
development and marketing the business
leaves plenty of time to get away for
vacations with his wife and two young
daughters when his income from the
planners hits six figures a little under
two years ago he quit his job to work on
the business full-time and this is Tim
jumping back in I want to note a few
patterns here and that is that these
people very rarely those who succeed
throw caution to the wind and just quit
their jobs without income in place they
typically do it after moonlighting and
working say evenings or weekends to
prove that their new business works and
in some cases they will wait the span of
one or two or three years even if they
get the flight will spinning just to
double and triple confirm all right back
to the piece
just four years into running his still
profitable business full time he broke
two million in revenue and has seen his
life transformed Nadler is part of an
exciting trend the growth of ultra lean
one-person businesses that are reaching
and exceeding 1 million dollars in
revenue according to recent statistics
released by the US Census Bureau in 2015
there were thirty five thousand five
hundred and eighty four non employer
firms non employer and quotation marks
that is those who do not employ anyone
other than the owners that brought in 1
million to 2 million a four hundred and
ninety 9999 in annual revenue that's a
five point eight percent from 2014 18
percent from 2013
twenty-one percent from 2012 and 33
percent from 2011 while the Census
Bureau's label non employer firms which
you mentioned before defines these ultra
lean businesses by what they are not
many entrepreneurs clearly see them for
what they are an engine that offers the
potential for high income and a balanced
interesting life on their own terms
these businesses offer three things that
elude most workers today control over
their time enough money to enjoy it and
the independence to live life as they
want many entrepreneurs take one of two
paths in pursuit of economic freedom
today one quitting their jobs and
launching a traditional small business
such as a shop or a restaurant or two
trying to scale a start-up into the next
company to go public or get acquired by
a larger corporation but the million
dollar one-person business entrepreneurs
have embraced a new and third path one
in which a single individual or business
partner can extend their capabilities to
achieve what it would normally take a
larger team to do what they're pulling
off takes effort but the changing nature
of work the growth of automation and
technological developments that unlock
market access are making it easier by
the day quote there's a way of thinking
that scales beyond them says Eric Scott
a partner at sci fi BC a venture firm in
San Francisco founded by Max Levchin
co-founder PayPal sidenote from Tim Max
is also in the latest book tribe of
mentors if you want more on max
fascinating guide right back to the
piece what's driving the growth of the
million dollar one-person business well
there are many factors one factor is the
internet and technology which has
enabled individual entrepreneurs to
plunge into a vast global mark
could place cheaply and quickly it has
become much easier to quickly set up a
business as legal structure operations
and distribution says Scott thanks to
cloud-based storage buying expensive
servers once a huge barrier to entry for
tech startups is no longer mandatory for
instance that is one of many many
different examples almost anything's is
back to Tim almost anything can be found
on a contract or software-as-a-service
basis including all sorts of customer
service and and otherwise and that
draining sound in the background is by
icemaker just for a little audio Verret
a for all of you
audio Verte fans out there alright back
to the piece the uptick also reflects a
shift in attitudes rather than adopt
Henry Ford era business models and which
scaling up depends on hiring legions of
employees these entrepreneurs choose to
travel light when they need to expand
their individual capabilities they often
deliberately turn to contractors or
firms that handle billing and other
outsourcing functions and approach some
first considered after being introduced
to the idea of outsourcing in the 4-hour
workweek all right now we move on to the
next section and there's a short section
on effectively getting started how to
get started and then we go back into the
case studies this is from Tim so how do
you get from where you are currently in
your career to enjoying the freedom
million-dollar entrepreneurs have it
starts with forming an idea of the type
of business you want to run in the
lifestyle you want it to support while
Nadler is passionate about planners
thinking about a daily planner might be
a slow form of torture for you what you
obsess about is electronic gadgets stock
market investing paleo cooking funky
handbags or collecting ceramic garden
gnomes your million-dollar business idea
probably has something to do with that
interest back to Tim and I'm gonna be
interrupting this way quite a bit read
1,000 true fans by Kevin Kelly
especially the updated version that he
put together for tools of Titan's you
can find it online just search 1,000
true fans Kevin Kelly it's on KK org and
what he will highlight for you and make
the mathematical case for is that even
if you have a one in a million interest
all right so if I don't know why this
fetish comes to mind but if you have a
sexual fetish maybe because I've toured
what used to be king calm in San
Francisco in the armory if it's still
around check it out but if you have some
odd fetish if you have some obsession
with a particular type of Japanese maid
watch let's just say like Seiko for
instance and a particular model even
one-in-a-million interest and you want
to develop a business around that one in
a million when you consider the billions
of people on this planet can still
provide a very profitable business that
can fuel the rest of your life and
perhaps the lives of everyone in your
family
so check out 1,000 true fans but it's
very true as she sang whether it's not
even stock market vesting but say event
based shorting of stocks or something
really esoteric you can find a small
group that can if you provide them with
incredible value fund your life
completely most likely with plenty of
buffer for other things alright so back
to your interest a good place to start
is by asking yourself some key questions
and that part on sexual fetishes is not
in millions because question what are
you really passionate about where can
you deliver value to people and would
you actually enjoy turning your idea
into a business and you may find that
there's some passions you prefer to keep
as personal interests instead and this
is this is very very true because you
might have something say like surfing
which gives you great release of stress
on the weekends when you wake up lazily
on a Saturday or Sunday and go hit the
waves but if you have to do that
nine-to-five with board I bankers and so
on every day Monday to Friday that might
change your relationship to something
that you currently love all right it's
very important to keep in mind but you
can also ask this is a question from Tim
that someone asked me at one point that
I found helpful what do you find easy to
do that many of your friends find hard
that is another question that can be an
additional circle and the Venn diagram
that you can use to find an intersection
that might allow you to build a
successful business all right
back to it the founders a million-dollar
one-person businesses and partnerships
are everyday people who have grown very
smart about the time they spend working
solo businesses and partnerships that
hit the million dollar range typically
fall into six categories keeping in mind
that Elaine looked at and canvassed
dozens of different businesses to
include in her book and as journalists
has interacted with hundreds and
hundreds more all right so what are the
six categories one ecommerce two
manufacturing
three informational content creation for
professional services and creative
businesses such as marketing firms
public speaking businesses and
consultancies five personal service
firms offering expertise such as fitness
coaching six real estate in interviewing
the entrepreneurs for the million dollar
one-person business again the book I
recommend checking out that's from Tim I
found that no two were alike but what
many have in common is that they were
using outsourcing automation mobile
technology or combination of all three
to build operate and grow their
businesses this includes as a side note
I've had enough caffeine to want to
interject a lot today people who are
working full time very successfully at
companies I met one
gent who works at Google he is not
technical but works at Google who has a
side business selling bracket install
kits for mounting or say mounting kits
for putting flatscreen displays up in
homes like televisions and so these are
brackets and mounting kits that he sells
via Shopify and he's turned it into I
want to say a high six-figure even
seven-figure business while he is still
maintaining his other job because he
happens to enjoy his job at Google so
there are many many many different forms
that this can take all right back to
Ellen some of these entrepreneurs have
made a commitment to remain sole
operations while others eventually
decided to scale the traditional way by
hiring employees that isn't what is most
important about their stories the point
of the million dollar one-person
business said it gives you choices
whether to keep it small while earning a
great income or continue growing it
neither path you'll notice involves the
pain of struggling in a marginal
freelance business that's important
often these entrepreneurs mentioned to
me so me in this case is Elaine this is
going to get confusing sorry guys
alright
these entrepreneurs mentioned to me
mentioned to Elaine that
for our work we gave them valuable ideas
on how to extend that one person or a
team of partners or rather what one
person or a team partners could do
before they hired employees here are
some of those stories which illustrate
how they applied the lessons at the
4-hour workweek and incredible results
they achieved in their lives because of
that case study number one split testing
for profit Nadler back to Nadler
remember laszlo Nadler never planned to
be an entrepreneur he studied business
management and technology and then built
a career as a project manager for one of
the top trading units at a multinational
bank it was a good job that seemed to
justify the college tuition his parents
had paid and enabled him to support his
young family and yet as Natalie was
talking almost six years ago with his
oldest daughter about the importance of
doing what you love his words sounded
Hollow he realized he was not following
his own advice what did excite him and
had led to his career in project
management rather was improving his own
productivity in helping the people
around him to do the same Nadler decided
it was time to actually follow the
advice he had given his daughter and
soon started a side business designing
and producing his own planners and
selling them online his goal was to
create a side income by creating a truly
automated business that would give him
the freedom to choose to work or not on
any given day an online store he
realized was the quickest and easiest
route to doing that quote the 4-hour
workweek got me started says Nadler
quote tim created the system to automate
his income to make space for the things
he loved and travel where he wanted to
go I was inspired to hack the system to
question the status quo and see if I
could pull it off myself and behold it
works
end quote unlike most day books Nadler
planners are not built around making
to-do lists instead they focus you on
the essential outcomes each week that
will move you forward toward your
primary goals many people love this idea
and bought the planners one thing that
helped Nadler was using automated
approaches to doing things like
conducting a bee testing to determine
how consumers were responding to his
webpages a time-saving idea he got after
reading the 4-hour workweek and there
there are a few non specifics in this
piece in this blog post that I'll just
throw out ideas for so for split testing
there are many many different options
you can check out if you want to create
for instance landing pages very quickly
you can check out I think it's leadpages
there are
it's like Optimizely that also will help
you to consider split testing different
elements on sites and many many other
options back to the piece in a is for
automation which is a section in the
4-hour workweek there's there is a
portion looking at software to help
readers and internet businesses
determine which combination of headlines
text and images on their homepage result
in the most sales instead of trying to
test all variables themselves meaning
independently by hiring a web developer
to tweak each and then look at the
numbers and so on you not only want
something that can make that easy you
want something that makes the
interpretation of the data very very
easy very very straightforward as a
non-technical person if that's you
Nadler acted on what he'd learned by
turning to the site split Lea so this is
another example so split Lea is yet
another option this saves him hours and
hours of manual work Nadler has found
the site's small team offers smart
insights to the questions he's trying to
answer quote the size of your company
doesn't matter when you have the right
brains and quote he notes case study
number two mastering the art of
delegation Ben and Camille arne berg
that's a RN EB ERG sorry if I'm
butchering that a married couple who
live in Austin Texas go Austin Texas
that's where I am right now left behind
traditional careers his in the Air Force
and hers and corporate social
sustainability to launch their upscale
housewares business willow and Everett
and that's willow and Andy Everett Evie
er ett comm willow never comm in 2015
and I checked it out they have some
really cool stuff for cold brew of all
things I like those containers anyway at
the time there were just 25 and neither
had any experience in retail but they
decided they wanted to hit a very
concrete goal 1 million dollars in
revenue
reading the 4-hour workweek helped them
find the courage to leave behind
traditional careers and build a
lifestyle they loved I should know for
those who haven't read the book that
there are really important preliminary
steps you take even if you are
ultimately going to quit before you quit
your job so you ensure that you have
safety nets of various types built in
and some type of financial means to
cover your bases if you search on tim
dot blog lifestyle cost
there are calculators and so on that
help you run through some of those
exercises so do not just decide to jump
into the water headfirst without
checking depth that is not what I
recommend and and these these folks this
particular couple I know did this very
methodically alright so for Camile
reading the comfort challenges in Tim
Ferriss this book where he offers ideas
on how to break out of your fear of not
conforming to social expectations by
doing something weird or ridiculous like
publicly relaxing by laying on the
sidewalk helped your questioned the
beliefs that we're keeping her tied to
her corporate life the first step to
leaving it behind quote the 4-hour
workweek helps you challenge social
norms and what people expect of you end
quote she says alright this requires
some explanation
so the relaxing in public doing public
laydowns this is something that now tens
of thousands hundreds of thousands of
people have done and taking photographs
of and it's quite hilarious and really
all it involves and I should mention as
context the book includes comfort
challenges these exercises every chapter
or few chapters because information does
you absolutely no good in the case of a
prescriptive non-fiction book if you
don't put them into action and some of
the decisions and actions will be
uncomfortable you've self selected by
buying a book to address these problems
for these things to be uncomfortable for
you and therefore I want people to get
progressively more comfortable with
discomfort so there's fear of
comfortable action expands so they can
then make the decisions and take the
actions necessary to craft a lifestyle
and a business that serves it and some
of them would include very simple things
right so for instance going into a
crowded area where you're not going to
get trampled or cause any problems and
just laying down on the ground for say
ten seconds this could be in Starbucks
you're in Lyon you lay down on the
ground for ten seconds if somebody looks
at you and asks you if they ask you are
you okay you say yep just taking a
little break
and you count it out you don't say
anything else and then you just get up
and continue as if nothing had happened
at all and there are there are various
different versions of this but that
would be one example and
so you learn very quickly the downside
of that is next to nothing another
option from a friend Noah Kagan who's
going to come up later in this piece
would be the coffee challenge and that
is walking up in a coffee shop or a
restaurant anywhere else where there is
a counter where you order in asking for
ten percent off of something for a lot
of people that's going to be coffee
because you drink coffee every day you
have an opportunity to do this and it
doesn't matter what the person says
whether they agree disagree or otherwise
you can't tell them you're doing an
experiment you can't make it easier for
yourself but you have to ask them for
ten percent off keep it simple and you
can give them a smile if you want and
they'll probably reject you that's
that's the whole point if they don't
reject you congratulations you just got
ten percent off but this is another form
of increasing your comfort with
discomfort all right
questioning those social norms and there
are probably a dozen of these in the
book all right back to the piece for
Camille and Ben and ditching the Air
Force and corporate social
responsibility to launch their upscale
house where as business will own Everett
here we go to make a smooth transition
from their traditional careers key
phrase smooth transition all right the
on Burke's eased into the
Entrepreneurship gradually both love
living an active lifestyle Ben was on
the airforce parachute team while
Camille is a certified personal trainer
and they initially tried selling
compression sleeves which is a running
accessory in this case on the Internet
on the side when that business did not
take off and it very often takes a few
at-bats folks this is Tim talking again
to get it right you might have to test a
few ways and that is why it's important
to determine how to inexpensively and
quickly test alright so when that
business did not take off they began
researching other products they could
sell on the giant trade marketplace
alibaba.com
and decided to build a store around
their passion for home entertaining they
invested about five thousand dollars in
inventory obtained through a sourcing
agent in China they found through a
freelance marketplace raising some of
the cash from friends and family which
is what I did to start my first business
- I basically went around my office
asking people to commit to buying one
unit of the product in advance which is
not that expensive like 50 bucks just so
I could afford the initial manufacturing
run so there ways to do this raising
some of the cash from friends and family
looking at it as much as an
investment in their own education
similar to a college course even if it
all went down the tube their reason the
experience would be valuable this is how
I have made several big shifts and
complete I suppose lateral moves in my
life and this is that would include
angel investing and technology startup
involvement which has become the vast
majority of my net worth and if you want
to know exactly how I did that
you can you can go to tim dot blog
forward slash MBA like masters and
Business Administration
Tim da plug forward slash MBA and it
talks about it gives you a real example
of how I created a real world MBA
deciding to invest money over two years
into something called the Tim Ferriss
fund which I made up wasn't actually
structurally a thing instead of going to
Stanford Business School and how I
thought about it how I psychologically
prepare myself to lose that money as a
sunk cost in other words as tuition but
optimizing for the skills and
relationships I would develop that would
then be my return on investment much
like getting an MBA so you can check
that out teamed up blog forward slash
MBA but in this case this couple
approached the five thousand dollars in
inventory and getting into manufacturing
and so on to tackle home entertaining as
a worthwhile cost even if it failed
right then that is an important
psychological preset all right the
couple opted to launch their site on a
giant ecommerce marketplace and we don't
have any specificity here so who knows
maybe that's Amazon maybe it's something
else I have no idea reckoning that this
would give them the exposure they needed
quickly the site grew quickly thanks to
the couple's eye for selecting stylish
but affordable products like decorative
shot glasses to stay focused on the high
level decisions to grow their revenue
the armed Berg's
didn't try to do everything themselves
and taking a cue from what they learned
in the 4-hour workweek outsource tasks
like and outsource continually customer
service and photography for the site
customer service platforms changed
really quickly so I'm not going to give
specific recommendations there are
photography there are many different
ways you can go about it
and if you're looking for design
specifically you can check out something
like 99designs for instance which i've
used in many different cases all right
so they outsourced both of those things
they also outsource order fulfillment
relying on their retail platform to
handle this so the retail platforms
it could include Shopify which I'm
biased for of course and they're the
market leader because I well begin
advising them when they had nine
employees now they're publicly trading
to have 2500 or 3000 something like that
or BigCommerce and there are others more
and so you can compare many many
different options as you would like them
right so they relied on the retail
platform to help them handle order
fulfillment there are also separate
fulfillment houses you could search your
city fulfillment house if you want it to
do something locally you might consider
as I did early in the day using a
fulfillment house in the middle of the
country so that you can use something
like priority mail or even USPS or UPS
ground and still get in effect one or
two day delivery which will thrill your
customers but charge less for shipping
or pay less or yourself so I had mine in
Tennessee so you could look at an option
like that if you are keeping those
considerations in mind and back to the
piece another example of how they
outsource is by relying on a private
label manufacturer overseas who
customizes their products for them
instead of trying to become
manufacturers themselves to avoid
getting involved in distracting minutiae
they actively empower their contractors
to make judgment calls such as issuing a
refund that would cost the company $50
or less a general concept they learned
in the 4-hour workweek Ferriss empowered
both his own assistants to resolve such
problems if it cost him $100 or last
quote it's about being smart strategic
and trusting others to make decisions
end quote says Ben all right so it's a
little bit more on this which is an
important concept to grasp what I
realized at one point in my first
business which was sports nutrition
ended up getting up to about 12
countries and distribution is I was I
was the bottleneck for many decisions
that I didn't need to be a bottleneck
for this was in 2004 that I really hit
the breaking point because I was
spending who knows let's just call it 20
30 hours a week answering questions like
hey there is a an Olympic athlete who is
trained
in Finland and they need this product
overnighted what should we charge and
because of customs and this this this is
that the other thing and what I decided
to do was for the fulfillment houses the
manufacturers for other people I said I
am no actually not in the case of the
manufacturer because I would oversee
that but in the case of fulfillment
customer service and so on I said I am
and I didn't just say I sent an email
indicating I am no longer your customer
consider my customers you our customers
if you can fix anything for less than
$100 please make that decision put it
into an Excel spreadsheet and then I
will review those Excel spreadsheets say
once a week and then once every two
weeks and then once a month and then
once every quarter overtime learning
what to ignore because the disasters
have not come to pass and everything is
going just swimmingly and over time I
took that maximum allowable autonomous
decision-making threshold from $100 up
to 500 up to $1,000 so they got to the
point where say anything less than
$1,000 to fix you can make the decision
let's just say for instance if
hypothetically I were off the grid and
turned out that the manufacturer was
going to have a bottleneck because a
certain ingredient was short in supply
and they would be in contact with say
the fulfillment center the fulfillment
center could make the decision or the
manufacturer could make the decision to
stockpile a certain ingredient that
would be a higher upfront cost that
would allow us not to miss orders say
three weeks later those are the types of
things that that would enable alright
here we go
so Ben just said it's about being smart
and strategic and trusting others to
make decisions by eliminating
unimportant tasks the iron Burke's are
able to follow entrepreneur and venture
capitalist Paul Graham's
makers versus managers schedule or
managers versus makers schedule an idea
Ferriss also practices and I've talked
about quite a bit Paul Graham is one of
the cofounders of something called Y
Combinator it's like the spec to Tim
it's like the Harvard meets Navy SEALs
of startup incubators for lack of a
better description and fascinating guy
fascinating story many essays that are
worth reading so I'd suggest looking up
Paul Graham if you don't know who he is
specifically I would recommend if you're
an entrepreneur checking out managers
versus makers schedule and if you google
that I'll pop right up Ben and Camille
break up their day into the managers
part focused on strategy and business
growth and the more task focused maker
part where they tackle high-impact tasks
best done by them in uninterrupted
blocks of time all right so back to Tim
there are ways you can do this and batch
activities which is something that I
really harp on repeatedly in the 4-hour
workweek to avoid task switching cost
which is which is a real cognitive
problem for most knowledge workers all
right you wouldn't for instance wash
laundry every time you have a dirty pair
of socks you wait for a certain critical
mass and then you wash laundry or doing
the dishes so on that applies to
cognitive tasks as well and just a few
examples of how you might do that one
could be checking email at certain times
during the day furthermore you could do
that with say Gmail offline so that
you're processing
email linearly or you could do something
like email game G AME if it's still
around which I found very useful and
used for a period of time to address
email linearly without having the
distraction of immediate responses
coming back to you and creating that
anxiety of the ship filling with water
faster than you can bail water out other
options for the makers versus managers
schedule the makers schedule requiring
large uninterrupted blocks of time is to
not just look at how you can break your
day into maker versus manager but how
you can break your week into maker
versus manager days and this is
something that I took from the schedule
of Jack Dorsey famed entrepreneur you
can look him up at Jack on Twitter how
did he get that handle check him out
he'll be able to figure it out pretty
quickly very very well known
entrepreneur and read about his schedule
at one point and and how it was
looking out by function day by day and
I've decided for instance to do most of
my recording on Mondays and Fridays I
break those out Mondays and Fridays for
scheduling purposes and my assistant
knows this for phone calls and recording
purposes
those are my recording days my long-form
a conversation tastes as it were and
then I will set say every two weeks a
day for administrative / accounting
cleanup in housekeeping where I'll get
in touch with the people who might need
certain types of documents or answers to
questions from me all right so there are
many different ways that you can block
out manager versus maker time on a daily
end on a weekly basis from me my maker
period is usually up to lunch and so I
try not to be reactive my phone is very
very often on airplane mode until lunch
at which point I can turn it on and
start trying to dodge bullets or respond
to inbound all right timmi timmi timmi
is interrupting the flow of this essay
for God's sake let me continue all right
during the manager part this is for them
they focus on coming up with new ideas
for growing willow in Everett as well as
new business opportunities to pursue the
results of those sessions have been
powerful last year they launched a
second business on the crowdfunding site
Kickstarter it sells the cube fit that's
one word cube fit Tara mat ter RA an
ergonomic mat for people use standup
desks the couple raised more than a
hundred thousand dollars so one hundred
and eight thousand or so to bring the
project to fruition and a campaign that
started in December 2016
and if since grown it to more than 1
million dollars in revenue well recently
they ran a successful Kickstarter
funding campaign for a new product
cold brew on tap that's the name of it
cold brew on tap this past fall raising
more than 56 thousand dollars and
shipping the product to backers in
December 2017 just a few months ago so
congratulations guys none of this would
have happened if they had not made an
active commitment to outsourcing and
staying focused on what really matters
it's important to protect that space
says Ben which comes back to that
question I suggested to you guys what do
you find easy that many of your friends
find hard and that may indicate what
your unique strengths are which is where
you should focus instead of deciding how
much it should cost for something to get
shipped ups to day to a customer it's
one example case study number three
fewer distractions equals more growth
danfa jela and Dan I apologize if I'm
screwing up your last name f8g GTL la
danfa jela 29 is a black belt in
Brazilian jiu-jitsu Vaghela earned
enough money to support himself in grad
school by running a small martial arts
gym he owned in his 20s but had it sold
by age 25 with the goal of creating a
scalable location independent internet
business in 2012 he launched science of
skill that's science of scale comm if
you want to check it out a
subscription-based ecommerce site that
initially sold online courses in martial
arts as a fighter Vaghela who has a
slight belt that achieved some renown
among martial arts for fight in which he
beat a much larger competitor many
people found his matches instructive
online videos of his competitions and
eventually those of other instructors
drew visitors to science of skills
website and reading the book scaling up
by Verne Harnish and listening to the
4-hour workweek audiobook during a 7
hour drive from Rhode Island to
Philadelphia proved to be pivotal
experiences that helped Vaghela grow his
business to the next level the
entrepreneur recalls the 4-hour workweek
opened for gelas mind two key ideas that
helped him grow his revenue far beyond
the average non employer business : hard
to hit the colon in audiobook format
alright these are the the two key ideas
growing a business without hire
additional employees and finding the
right communication rhythms with his
team one idea that really resonated with
Vaghela after running a traditional
brick-and-mortar business was Faris's
idea of working with a remote team of
contractors he found it freeing to
realize that he didn't necessarily need
a physical space for his team in this
case at science of skill would work
together under one roof quote that's an
idea that jumped out at me he says the
ease with which that can be done became
evident I knew that was going to be the
way to fuel the big game to find remote
contractors for tasks such as
copywriting and web support Vaghela
turned to the freelance platform oDesk
which is now part of upwork he built the
team of four
reliable contractors to handle tasks
such as copywriting and web support
quick pro tip from me for anyone testing
really any type of potential hire
whether they're contractors or otherwise
and certainly using these virtual
platforms test your top candidates if
you choose five candidates give them a
very very simple task with a short
turnaround let's just say hypothetically
48-hour turnaround with a set time as a
deadline and give the task to all of
them and use that to vet for the people
who can actually hit deadlines focus on
the ability to deliver on deadlines
before you vet any further with more
complex subject matter or or tasks for
that matter it doesn't matter how good
they are if they don't get you what you
need on time all right here we go Fidel
also learned another key lesson from the
4-hour workweek the right cadence of
communication with the team he found it
helpful to learn the first only checked
his email twice a day and made conscious
decisions about when he would
communicate with his team and how often
I for instance have currently a
15-minute stand-up meeting via phone
with my team every day at the same time
and I have a weekly call with my entire
team and there are formats for running
these calls successfully the way that
the call is introduced and then what
people bring up and then what they bring
up or primarily any wins to highlight
something uplifting for the team which
is done very very quickly and then also
done quickly bringing up any blockers or
obstacles that I need to help with
alright so there is a set schedule for
these types of things and we now have
one in-person off-site I would say the
cadence is roughly it would appear if
I'm looking at my calendar every six
months or so now back to Fidel a quote
it wasn't an unbroken consistent stream
of messages back and forth but was an
organized way of communicating that
keeps things moving and functioning
notes Vaghela
you could kind of bucket when you
actually handle your digital
communication and talk to these folks
were thousands of miles away it became
self-evident to me that these things
were manageable and quote by
establishing similar communication
rhythms to communicate with team members
in other time zones such as his
developer and designer in India for
jello protected his time
that he needed to focus on big-picture
strategizing that helped him grow signs
of skill the direct result was that he
gradually expanded his offerings beyond
the martial arts world to offer products
related to self-protection and
self-reliance and ongoing curriculum for
self-defence and martial arts techniques
became one of his biggest products that
expansion helped him make the leap from
six-figure to seven-figure revenue prior
to hiring employees quote the tools and
concepts in the 4-hour workweek were
critical for science of skill he says in
2017 Fidelis sold science of skill for
more than a million dollars to a group
of software entrepreneurs from Ohio as
he got ready to sell Vaghela hired one
full-time person and one part-time
employee to run it he understood that he
needed to demonstrate to potential
owners that someone else could run the
business successfully without his
involvement very important to note here
that he did this before attempting to
sell the company
and there's a book called built to sell
by Jon Warlow that I think is very
helpful for thinking about this even if
you never intend to sell your business
it's helpful to look at your business
and ask in six months what would I need
to do to sell it and that will force you
to remove a lot of stupid current
behaviors which are stymieing you and
keeping you busy instead of productive
potentially so built sell would be one
of them the e-myth revisited would be
another that I found very very helpful
certainly when I was starting my own
business as well and you might ask why
would Fidelis sell science of skill for
more than a million if he was generating
six high six or seven figure income and
that you have to keep in mind that or
revenue so you have to keep in mind that
a revenue does not equal income all
right so post tax returns after
everything is subtracted and secondly
there are points for instance when I was
running my own business where you could
continue to milk the cow from a cash
flow perspective but it does always
consume at least say 10% of your RAM
your browser is always a little bit slow
and you at some point might just want to
offload that business and really clear
your mental palate completely by selling
it which is also what I ended up doing
in 2009 all right the month before
Fidelis old signs of skill it was
bringing in two hundred and ten thousand
dollars a month in revenue that sale
helped him fund
his current startup tech emergence which
you can find at tech emergence comm a
media and market research firm in San
Francisco that has focused on artificial
intelligence a subject that fascinates
him quote that's the stuff I'm super
duper passionate about he says all right
so that is the story of Denver jela up
to this point many more adventures to be
had and stories to be told I'm sure case
study number four success through
liberation and liberation is another
section that talks about Geographic
mobility and geo arbitrage which we
don't have time to get into right now
but Seoul Orwell 32 lives in downtown
Toronto has grown his business examined
calm two seven-figure revenue while
traveling the world I'm gonna pause here
for a dramatic sip of tea for those
interested it is chaga tea from four sig
Matic decaf back to Seoul seven-figure
revenue while traveling the world what
let's get into this creating a business
that allows him to live the way he
wanted didn't happen overnight
for years Orwell experimented with a
variety of businesses online gaming
domain names local search and daily
deals until he found the ideal approach
to make it happen
one thing that finally freed Orwell to
achieve his goal is reading the 4-hour
workweek the L is for liberation section
it's the fourth section and they're in
order and you're supposed to implement
them an order definition elimination
automation liberation so liberation is
the fourth really resonated with him it
showed him how to cut the leash to
traditional office work and create the
freedom to travel Orwell was intrigued
by the idea of a mini retirement where
instead of waiting until you're done
working travel meaning retiring right
instead of waiting until retirement to
travel you redistribute mini retirements
throughout life quote that switch and
mindset has begotten me so many positive
consequences I cannot even begin to
count them end quote he says looking for
a way to achieve his own liberation
Orwell realized he needed to put systems
in place to free him from his daily
responsibilities that might otherwise
prevent him from traveling thanks to
income from his various ventures being
able to pay for travel was not an issue
for him so he had the money he just
didn't have the mobility and I should
know that there are ways to do this and
and it is critical to schedule these
times off the grid
one of the best ways to take your
business to the next level I think in a
the most psychologically and emotionally
gratifying way is to and I'm often asked
about how do I take my business to the
next level and I said well if you're a
small business owner and by small
business I mean headcount not
necessarily revenue so if you have very
few employees and you are currently the
primary decision-maker taking four to
eight weeks off the grid minimum four
and and putting that in the calendar
paying for it in advance
committing ideally to say take family
members with you
so they will bust your balls and be
disappointed and sad if you don't do it
I told you accountable is very very
helpful because you will have to put
systems and policies in place that allow
people to make up these autonomous
decisions that we talked about earlier
that I was setting financial thresholds
for or limits for rather and those
systems will remain in place and will
provide dividends long after you get
back from your mini-vacation
a two-week vacation does not work a
one-week vacation doesn't work because
you can allow the fires to explode and
then come back and play firefighter for
weeks eight weeks you can't do that
because everything will be consumed by
fire you actually have to put the
systems in place the if this then that
the decision-making frameworks putting
together at Google Docs so that you know
or you can convey exactly how to perform
a certain function for instance back to
Seoul all right although Orwell was
experienced in delegating work to
contractors from his previous ventures
reading the 4-hour workweek helped him
realize he needed to step out of the
day-to-day completely at examine calm
quote after having spent years building
up my business instead of attempting to
just continue growing it I put my number
two in charge I trusted him and killed
my own job and then I galavant it around
the globe he says gotta love that word
galavant 'add mobile access to the
Internet was so extensive by that point
he says that quote ever went I could
work dot dot dot if I wanted to end
quote this is actually a really
important point so you can work almost
anywhere you go thanks to broadband
Wi-Fi access and it's going to be
important if you take your first minion
retirement use a place where that is
exceptional
difficult and maybe deliberately use a
phone that does not operate overseas
which is what I do
thanks Verizon or it doesn't function
very well overseas in any case and I'll
use whatsapp for say communication with
family and that necessitates just
finding Wi-Fi hotspots so I might have
one at a hotel or an Airbnb and then one
elsewhere say at coffee shops or
what-have-you and or if you do have
broadband access really really
determining exactly when you're gonna
batch any type of business obligations
if you have to do that for me when I was
traveling from in 2004 I ended up
planning a four week trip to London to
rethink all these systems and put them
in place which turned into 18 months
around the world and I would typically
do all of my business tasks I would
handle those obligations on Mondays and
I had one hour blocked out before lunch
with friends to do that so those are a
few ways you can think about it
all right so everywhere I went I could
work if I want to or want to toot says
so the key to pulling this off was
working with the right contractor or
well who had initially gotten interested
in nutrition while losing weight had
become friendly with a fellow
contributor to the fitness community on
reddit and was impressed by the way in
which his buddy shared his expertise
with others on the site quote the most
important part was how patient he was
well says he continues he would write
these long answers Orwell was equally
impressed by the way his friend handled
challenging feedback without getting
angry quote reddit is not the
friendliest place it can be friendly not
always and says Orwell he took it very
evenly unquote
these were qualities that would serve
him well in an internet business like
Orwell's where customers often reached
out with their own questions about
nutrition oral had soon enlisted his
friend as a contractor to run examine
calm day-to-day offering a small amount
of equity to ensure his buddy was
invested in his success Orwell found the
arrangement worked beautifully when it
came to indulging his love of travel
quote giving him the authority to do
whatever he needed to do implicitly
brought initiative and quote Orwell says
to make sure the site had credibility or
will also hire a group of expert
contractors such as PhDs to evaluate the
research on various nutritional
supplements and write reports on them
quote using contractors was not only
about simplifying our lives and
processes but making sure we had the
best knowledge or information on that
specific topic and quote as the company
grew and expanded in new products such
as its research digest and newsletter
aimed at professionals or well brought
in an author equity partner though his
number two eventually moved on to other
pursuits the company continues to thrive
and grow with examined comm generating
millions of page views a month or well
now wants to scale up in a more
traditional way and this year began the
transition to adding traditional
employees so I should note even if your
ultimate goal is to this is Tim again
add headcount in the form of traditional
employees which is a viable path
certainly it makes sense very often to
kick the tires and ensure that you have
clearly defined the roles you need to
hire for by testing with contractors
first you may decide that certain jobs
are not worth having done at all because
certain projects are not worth doing at
all and you don't hire someone excellent
at doing something that is best not done
at all a point that is made in the
effective executive by Peter Drucker a
fantastic book that I reread often
all right so even if your intention is
to move to full time employees very
often it makes incredible financial
sense to test that in a way that is
easily reversible with contractors
freelancers of some type all right back
to Saul so he wants to scale in a more
traditional way now fantastic given that
he has structured the company in a way
that he does not have to micromanage
everyone or well still has the freedom
to travel and give back to charity as
much as he wants recently his
chocolate-chip cookie off NYC ex benefit
which I looked up and there's a link to
it in the post on Tim da blog it is a
cookie off apparently hey there are 30
plus different types of cookies held at
the Strand bookstore in New York City
legendary book store raised more than 30
thousand dollars for the nonprofit she's
the first which supports girls in
low-income countries will be the first
in their families to graduate from high
school
Orwell's next goal is figuring out I
raise $50,000 per event to multiply the
impact even more that's something he
probably wouldn't have had the time or
mental space to tackle it
I hadn't decided to embrace his own
liberation which again refers to that
Geographic mobility all right
case study number five is rethinking
scale and profit jayson gaignard J a yso
n then Gagan RG AI GNA Rd who I know hi
Jason
founded and runs mastermind talks and I
actually didn't know him until he put
together this mastermind talks which is
a whole different story anyway founded
and runs mastermind talks which you can
find at mmm t dot community mmm t dot
community a Toronto based firm that
brings together a carefully selected
group of entrepreneurs in a by
application only annual event the
company which gig nerd runs with some
help from his wife and assistant who was
a contractor and very recently a content
and community manager that could all
easily expand and its kind of plug and
play the way that's been organized about
4,000 to 5,000 people apply annually to
participate in mastermind talks and the
event only accepts 150 entrepreneurs
Gegard has made a conscious decision to
keep the business to a size this
particular size as a direct result of
reading 4-hour work week he read the
book in 2008 when he had been an
entrepreneur for about three years and
recalls vividly how life-changing the
story of the fables of fortune hunters
was for him at the time and we're gonna
dig into this in a second quote I have
very few moments like that he says so
what is the fables of fortune hunters
story the tale is about an American
businessman and there are many versions
of this story I should say but the tale
is about in this case the the version
that was put into the 4-hour workweek an
American businessman with a Harvard MBA
whose burned out and takes a vacation to
a small coastal Mexican village on
doctor's orders and there's there's much
more to it it's worth reading this story
in the 4-hour workweek because the
emotional payoff comes with the lead up
to the punchline but I'm going to give
you the basic idea so at the pier as so
the story goes in the book you can't
sleep he's super anxious thinking about
things back home and he goes out for a
and he meets at Mexican fishermen with a
small boat on a pier and he who in this
fisherman lives a bucolic life with
plenty of time to spend with his
families and friends in a small
community the businessman encourages the
fishermen to scale up his operations by
buying more boats and fishing more and
do this and do this and do this and do
this and do this and each time this
American businessman makes some
suggestion the Mexican fisherman replies
with and then what's an yacht and then
what saying you're very politely and
this guy goes on and on oh no no no no
no no no no and in the beginning he
asked this fisherman how he spends his
time he's like well I have plenty of
time to spend with my family and friends
I go out fishing I catch what I need
then I come back I play the guitar and
we drink wine and watch the sunset and
then we start again the next day all
right
so and then what's in your and then what
and then what and then one this this
this businessman is just really getting
excited talking about all these ways
that he can scale scale scale scale
scale up until oh my god it's big enough
that he can expand his operations into
the United States take his company to an
initial public offering and catch out
with tens maybe hundreds of millions of
dollars and then he asks this American
businessman and then what senior and the
American says well and then you can
retire to a small coastal village in
Mexico where you can spend your time
with your family and friends go out
fishing when you want to play the guitar
and drink wine while you watch the
sunset the point being very often for
instance at least within a u.s. context
we experience this incredible quality of
life stay in college when we're [ __ ]
broke is [ __ ]
pardon my french earmuffs kids and we
spend the rest of our life trying to get
back to the quality of life in the
carefree nature with which we experience
life in psychology which doesn't require
a lot of money but we somehow convince
ourselves that it does and that's not to
say that money doesn't have a place it
does however that's the story that Jason
read reading the story says gay ignored
quote made me realize that I was on a
hamster wheel running a business I hate
it it fundamentally shifted my view on
scale I had a desire to build a big
business at that time but never
questioned it and quote at the time gig
nerd was running a business called
tickets Canada a tickets retailer in
Toronto so he was he was making 1.5
million
I knew from that he was taking home 350
K in profits if he could hit 3 million
he assumed he would double his profits
to 700,000 however he didn't anticipate
that higher overhead would prevent the
expected growth profits in fact when he
slaved away and grew to 3 million
his profits only hit four hundred
thousand dollars so he'd gone from 350
to 400 and he had to bring almost 20
people on staff to get there so this is
not a pretty picture he ended up in a
tough financial position where he was
considering bankruptcy reading the
4-hour workweek made him start
questioning the conventional wisdom on
scaling a business quote I had a desire
to build a big business at the time but
I never questioned it Gengar said it
made me realize that I was on a hamster
wheel running a business I hated I think
we already covered this but we gotta get
in the piece okay he eventually decided
to close tickets Canada quote it was the
biggest shift I've ever made in a
business for calls gate guard in 2011 a
friend invite Jason to see a talk my
marketing guru Seth Godin in New York
City Godin theme of networking with
like-minded individuals resonated with
gay canard and if you have a chance this
is Tim talking to see Seth Godin speak
see it Seth is so good he is a master at
the format really really expert so if
you can find an opportunity take it he
does very little speaking and has an
awesome way of vetting opportunities for
speaking he says no to almost anything
it's based on how close it is to his
home in New York the pricing is also
related to that in any case so Jason
sees Godin and is exposed to this theme
of networking with like-minded
individuals Gegard started holding
dinners where he would invite eight
interesting people embracing the idea of
developing his network gig nerd was new
to events but now that he was committing
to building a new way of living for
himself decided he would figure things
out as he went along he was delighted
when the event proved to be very
successful
that event morphed into his current
business mastermind talks the following
year despite constant encouragement to
grow his business gig nerd has decided
to keep it small paying himself $250,000
a year quote how much more money do I
need end quote
he says keeping the business small
allows him plenty of time to spend with
his wife and their young daughter and he
has no intention of letting go of the
perspective he gained from the 4-hour
workweek quote I became conscious of
designing my lifestyle and designing my
business to fit that lifestyle he's
this is really important this is a
really important point because it it can
be a social pressure to grow your
business and let it metastasize in some
cases beyond where it should be the
perfect size and there are other
resources I would recommend checking out
I believe it's small giants might be the
little giants I can never quite remember
by bo Burlingham is a book the profiles
many of these businesses that choose to
be the best focus on being the best at
what they do and not the biggest hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday event provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour work week
calm
that's 4-hour work week calm all spelled
out and just drop in if your email and
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom which more than 2 million
Americans have used to help start their
businesses past guests even such as
while WordPress lead developer CEO of
automatic Matt Mullenweg now valued at
more than a billion dollars have used
LegalZoom to help with their business
needs specifically in his case to form
his company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business their services
include everything from helping you to
manage changing tax laws reviewing
contracts creating NDA's non-disclosure
agreements employment stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience
that typically takes time and effort
away from running your business the best
part is that you won't get charged by
the hour because you'll zoom isn't a law
firm so they won't be running the clock
up and spinning circles just to raise
your bill instead they just ask you to
pay one low upfront price for whatever
it is that you're looking to get on a
cart style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T IM at checkout
capital TV lowercase I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him this episode is brought to you by
99designs whether you need a logo custom
website app book cover or anything else
99designs was created to make great
design accessible to everyone that's you
and to make the process as easy as
possible I've used 99 designs for years
now I've used them book covers some
mock-ups for the 4-hour body which went
on to become a number one York Times
best seller illustrations of all
different types for the multi-volume The
Tao of Seneca which you can check out
and other graphic design projects for a
long time now and I've been very
impressed by the quality of their
designers and illustrators and you don't
have to take my word for it you should
check out some of my projects at
99designs com forward slash Tim I really
encourage you to take a look because you
will be impressed 99designs campos / Tim
9m Designs has freelance experts in more
than 90 design categories in their
platform once you work directly with one
designer that you choose if you like
their stuff which is what I did for the
town Seneca or you can get concepts from
multiple designers and then make your
favorite so whether you're starting a
business or just looking for extra
design help resources etc 99designs
has a solution right now you guys my
listeners can receive a free $99 upgrade
on your first design to check out your
first free upgrade please visit
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
click the link on the landing page you
can also find there
samples of projects from you guys
listeners who have used 99 designs for
logos apps even product packaging so
check it out 99 designs calm poet / Tim
[Applause]
you
you